reviews are in for Lords of the Fallen
which is another Souls like that is
available on PS5 Xbox series s and x and
PC overall it has a 75 on Metacritic so
not quite as highly reviewed as lies of
P but there are some pretty positive
reviews in there too IGN gave it an
eight saying Lords of the Fallen is an
awesome Souls likee with a fantastic
jeel reality's premise even when
performance shortcomings and whiy bosses
crash the party on the other hand Game
Informer gave it a six out of 10 they
said despite a solid gameplay Foundation
stunning wild in a unique two realm
mechanic by the time I reach credits
after 48 hours I was overjoyed to be
done Xbox era gave a 9.4 they said Lords
of the Fallen is a stunningly good game
following a path set for it by dark
souls 3 at Nails every major part of
what makes froms game so damn good and
the lowest review that I could find is
from the sixth axis who gave it a four
out of 10 they said it's the first game
on year that has actively annoyed them
and then it seems like it just didn't
take any lessons from the first game
what do you guys think you going to be
playing it